pour moi en fait faire un régime il y en
a qui vont le faire parce qu'ils doivent
faire deux trois kilos donc le faire en
une semaine deux semaines perdre vite
oui mais quand on a 10 kilos à perdre il
faut prendre son temps pour le faire
après il faut savoir aussi que
il y en a beaucoup qui regardent la télé
il y en a beaucoup il y a beaucoup qui
marchent des animateurs
c'est quoi en fait c'est quoi la
normalité pour les hommes
mais les gens regardent les choses
différemment les réseaux sociaux sont
venus amplifier les choses et il faut
aussi rappeler aux jeunes rappeler aux
gens et c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit mon
livre il y a des filtres il y a des
retouches photos il faut pas croire tout
ce qu'on voit c'est pour ça que moi je
n'utilise aucun filtre que j'essaye
vraiment de faire voir les choses après
par exemple là on vient de me
diagnostiquer un lipoodème c'est-à-dire
que je fais du sport tous les jours je
fais attention à ce que je mange j'ai
perdu 25 kg mais j'aurais toujours les
jambes poteau c'est une maladie en fait
que une femme sur dix a qui est peu
connu en France qui est très connu en
Allemagne et en Espagne et du coup en
fait ça commence à se développer mais je
pourrais faire du sport à vie et en fait
ça ne partira pas je pourrais juste
diminuer tout ça j'en parlerai par la
suite mais avant de faire des régimes il
faut aller voir des spécialistes des
engiologues voir si on n'a pas des
problèmes au niveau de la thyroïde enfin
c'est hyper important parce que sinon
bah on peut se rendre malade c'est
vraiment une maladie c'est vraiment un
combat qu'on peut mener et peut des fois
à perte parce qu'en fait tu peux faire
tout ce que tu veux mais des fois il y a
des gens ils peuvent pas perdre ma mère
elle s'est fait opérer elle regrette en
fait elle a fait un bypass elle regrette
parce qu'elle peut plus manger de riz de
pâtes elles sont vraiment malade la
réduction de la réduction de l'estomac
il y en a plein qui en pleurent qui
pleure maintenant et pourtant c'est un
acte chirurgical il faut bien lire bien
réfléchir quelle est votre conseil pour
toutes les personnes qui font le yoyo
bah pour toutes les personnes qui font
le yoyo déjà se renseigner pour voir si
elles n'ont pas des problèmes quand j'ai
dit tout à l'heure de lipo
lipodème de thyroïde faire vraiment
attention il y a les tout doucement il
vaut mieux mettre un an pour perdre 10
kg plutôt que de mettre à 3 mois pour
perdre 10 kilos du coup provoquer des
problèmes dans sa santé faire attention
à ce qu'on mange parce que par exemple
moi à l'époque on m'avait dit des sushis
c'est pas grave bah c'est faux c'est
super gras faire attention comme on dit
on a une pizza que si sushis mais des
fois on a un nombre de calories à manger
par jour
une pizza c'est équivaut à 6 sushi en
fait c'est la quantité que tu manges
c'est la quantité il faut faire
attention à ce que tu manges c'est un
nom de calories par jour qu'on te prête
des Conseils de nutrition par contre sur
la viande la manger bien cuite parce que
ça enlève également ça c'est hyper
important